I do have to ask you Justin Bieber
either like Sam's or like liked your
pictures I'm still waiting for my D I'm
Justin Bieber like listen at all those
all the girls not my Raven Raven mine
who else I think just I think yeah What
did he say
yeah he's a huge bachelor fan yeah yes
he saw Paradise that's really sweet like
yeah like did you hang out in person how
did you do no we just I talked to him
like a normal person
[Laughter]
you've been through a lot of things in
his life recently and I feel like he
connected to people that were on
paradise that felt like they're going
through a while like he damn Dean - oh
yeah so did you consult like do you guys
like kind of event
you're like relationship issues - tell
me about life and like things ring you
know he's very connected to God right
now so we talked a lot about that it was
really nice he's in release weekend so
was there a bachelor party at his no I
wasn't invited
where did ya just go down you're
probably a dog Justin Bieber oh wow they
came over here I'm waiting for my demon
when was this right after paradise okay
and where I go down at is how no was it
ever romance no okay
so you've not just amber no no this is
so casual inion are you still in touch
with Justin Bieber
I know no I really know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]